wir gehen wieder in die ukraine wird in
dieses kriegs land zu unserem bild
reporter peter heller ist heute auf dem
land unterwegs sozusagen außerhalb von
kiews in der stadt schmidt ski und bei
ihm ist der bürgermeister dieser stadt
alexanders
gewinnst du dich peter was kannst du uns
von dort berichten
ja leider nichts gutes auch hier haben
gerade wieder die sirenen geheult auch
diese stadt ist ziel russischer bomben
und raketen wir sind gerade alle in den
bunker gerannt mussten uns in sicherheit
bringen und der bürgermeister von
kaminski alexander sergej witsch wie ist
die situation gerade gerade haben die
sirenen geheult wie lassen das mal
übersetzen wie gefährlich ist die lage
das geht das tor auf meniskus
arthroskopie in wien
lebt schon seit zehn tagen in einer
situation die man aber mit den wörtern
in situation des krieges die man mit den
worten nicht überhaupt übertragen kann
das audi fährt ist die schlimmste
situation überhaupt
alles was man da im fernsehen sieht kann
man auch dann mit wörtern nicht
übertragen
wo
und wann dieses boot
politische theorie nicht vor einer
stunde
wurde aber dann eine schule in der er
neben gebiet auto bombardiert das ist
aber dann unser neben gebiet gleich
gleich um die ecke schon sind sie
präpariert für den angriff
damit er aber dann klar versteht was
diese rennen dreimal hintereinander
bedeutet das bedeutet dass eine mama ihr
kennt aber dann in die arme nehmen muss
und in schutzbunker dann laufen soll und
wer an dieser cory cory
cory cory cory doctorow
rennen bedeutet das einen neugeborenen
ein neugeborenes kind in armen von von
mama auch dann in einem
glas schutzglas ich weiß nicht wie das
aber dann medizinischer genannt wird
aber trotzdem
brutkasten genauso danke mama muss auch
schutzbund anlaufen soll wir haben einen
angriff gab von den russen auf ein
atomkraftwerk 700 kilometer entfernt es
gibt ein atomkraftwerk 80 kilometer
entfernt kann er uns das mal zeigen wie
gefährdet die ecke ist hier hatte
allerdings gesagt
dass die mutter gesagt dass david marsh
um die vorher fragen dazu beantworten
also was passiert werden wie angegriffen
werden also da kann ich ja eins sagen
also während der das
bad der der feind herzukommen dann
machen wir ihn hier so eine hülle dass
er das nie mehr vergessen wird
die ist nicht sauer sind auch dann sehr
sehr friedliche menschen aber wenn der
feind hier dann wagt dann werden wir ihn
auch dann empfangen und total vernichten
als nächste aktion kraftwerk ist 80
kilometer von ihr entfernt kann er uns
zeigen wie gefährdet hier diese stadt
ist falls russland auch dieses
atomkraftwerk bombardiert
die maschine wurde der wagen zuerst
gesagt das gibt ihr motivation ist doch
man jetzt schon dadurch dass man sich
im norden von was bedeutet das wenn das
bombardiert werden
diese atomkraftwerk bombardiert werden
dann bekommen aber nicht nur die manager
nicht nur die ukraine das zu spüren
sondern auch dann europa westeuropa also
man weiß nicht wohin diese atomare wolke
dann hinzieht und berlin habe ich gehört
und berlin euro dann bekommt aber dann
geht das ganze europa tour was brauchen
sie für waffen wie können sie sich
schützen gegen anja katharina strack ist
er diesen job
als machen brauchen wir und vor allen
dingen brauchen wir auch etwas
zu machen weil die
flugzeuge
bombardieren alles deswegen also noch
mal stellt die frage stellt sich die
frage über unter himmel schutz
wir hören die verzweiflung auch jetzt
die nähe auch zu dem atomkraftwerk was
gerade mal 80 85 kilometer weiter
nördlich ist die angst ist immens hier
das was man hier unten im südwesten
hatte 700 kilometer von hier entfernt
kann auch hier passieren das heißt wenn
russland weiterhin so unpräzise bord
oder überhaupt weiterkommt dann besteht
die gefahr eines größten anzunehmenden
unfall ist eines super gaus und das
würde nicht nur die region hier in der
ukraine total verwüsten sondern eben
auch komplett westeuropa also wenn da
nicht jetzt gespräche stattfinden dann
gerät das noch mehr außer kontrolle und
wir sehen es sind nicht nur die waffen
die hier zerstören sondern eben auch die
atomanlage die europa eben wirklich
komplett kontaminieren können wenn sie
denn zerstört werden